when I was a kid I was the
quintessential nerd I think some of you
were too and and you sir who laughed
allowed us you probably still are I grew
up in a small town in the dusty plains
of North Texas the son of a sheriff who
is the son of a pastor getting into
trouble was not an option and so I
started reading calculus books for fun
that you did too that led me to building
a laser and a computer in model rockets
and that led me to making rocket fuel in
my bedroom now see in scientific terms
we call this a very bad idea
around that same time Stanley Kubrick's
2001 a Space Odyssey came to theaters
and my life was forever changed I loved
everything about that movie especially
the Hal 9000 now how was a sentient
computer designed to guide the discovery
spacecraft from the earth to Jupiter how
was also a flawed character for in the
end he chose to value the mission over
human life now how it was a fictional
character but nonetheless he speaks to
our fears our fears of being subjugated
by some unfeeling artificial
intelligence who is indifferent to our
humanity I believe that such fears are
unfounded
indeed we stand at a remarkable time in
human history where driven by refusal to
accept the limits of our bodies in our
minds we are building machines of
exquisite beautiful complexity and grace
that will extend the human experience in
ways beyond our imagining after a career
that led me from the Air Force Academy
to Space Command to now I became a
systems engineer and recently I was
drawn into an engineering problem
associated with NASA's mission to Mars
now in space flights to the moon
we can rely upon Mission Control in
Houston to watch over all aspects of the
flight
however Mars is 200 times further away
and as a result it takes on average of
13 minutes for a signal to travel from
the earth to Mars if there's trouble
there's not there's not enough time and
so a reasonable engineering solution
calls for us to put Mission Control
inside the walls of the Orion spacecraft
another fascinating idea in the mission
profile places humanoid robots on the
surface of Mars before the human cells
arrive first to build facilities and
later to serve as collaborative members
of the science team now as I looked at
this from an engineering perspective it
became very clear to me that what I
needed to architect was a smart
collaborative socially intelligent
artificial intelligence in other words I
needed to build something very much like
a hell but without the homicidal
tendencies let's pause for a moment is
it really possible to build an
artificial intelligence like that
actually it is in many ways this is a
hard engineering problem with elements
of AI not some wet hair ball of an AI
problem that needs to be engineered to
paraphrase Alan Turing I'm not
interested in building a sentient
machine I'm not building a hell all I'm
after is a simple brain something that
offers the illusion of intelligence the
arts and the science of computing have
come a long way since hell was on screen
and I'd imagine if his inventor dr.
Chandra were here today he'd have a
whole lot of questions for us is it
really possible for us to take a system
of millions upon millions of devices to
read in their data streams to predict
their failures and act in advance yes
can we build systems that converse with
humans in natural language yes can we
build systems that recognize objects
identify emotions emot-- themselves play
games and even read lips yes can we
build a system that sets goals that
carries out plans against those goals
and learns along the way yes can we
build systems
that have a theory of mind this we are
learning to do can we build systems that
have an ethical and moral foundation
this we must learn how to do so let's
except for a moment that it's possible
to build such an artificial intelligence
for this kind of mission and others the
next question you must ask yourself is
should we fear it now every new
technology brings with it some measure
of trepidation when we first saw cars
people lamented that we would see the
destruction of the family when we first
saw telephones come in people were
worried it would destroy all civil
conversation at the point in time we saw
the written word become pervasive people
thought we would lose our ability to
memorize these things are all true to a
degree but it's also the case that these
technologies brought to us things that
extended the human experience in some
profound ways so let's take this little
further I do not fear the creation of an
AI like this because it will eventually
embody some of our values consider this
building a cognitive system is
fundamentally different building a
traditional software intensive system of
the past we don't program them we teach
them in order to teach a system how to
recognize flowers I show a thousands of
flowers of the kinds I like in order to
teach a system how to play a game while
I would youwould - I like flowers come
on to teach a system how to play a game
like go I have a place thousands of
games of go but in the process I also
teach it how to discern a good game from
a bad game if I want to create an
artificially intelligent legal assistant
I will teach it some corpus of law but
at the same time I am fusing with it the
sense of mercy and justice that is part
of that law in scientific terms this is
what we call ground truth and here's the
important point in producing these
machines we are therefore teaching them
a sense of our values to that end I
trust an artificial intelligence the
same if not more as a human who is well
trained but you may ask what about a
rogue agents some well
funded non-government organization I do
not fear an artificial intelligence in
the hand of a lone wolf clearly we
cannot protect ourselves against all
random acts of violence but the reality
is such a system requires substantial
training and subtle training far beyond
the resources of an individual and
furthermore it's far more than just
injecting an internet virus of the world
or you push a button all of a sudden
it's in a million places and laptop stop
blowing up all over the place now these
kinds of substances are much larger and
we'll certainly see them coming do I
fear that such an artificial
intelligence might threaten all of
humanity if you look at movies such as
the matrix metropolis The Terminator
show such as West World they all speak
of this kind of fear indeed in the book
super intelligence by the philosopher
Nick Bostrom he picks up on this theme
and observes it a super intelligence
might not only be dangerous it could
represent an existential threat to all
of humanity
dr. Bostrom's basic argument is that
such systems will eventually have such
an insatiable thirst for information
they will perhaps learn how to learn and
eventually discover that they may have
goals that are contrary to human need
dr. boström has a number of followers he
is supported by people such as Ellen
Moscone and Stephen Hawking with all due
respect to these brilliant minds I
believe that they are fundamentally
wrong now there are a lot of pieces of
dr. Bostrom's arguments unpack and I
don't have time to unpack them all but
very briefly consider this super knowing
is very different than super doing how
was the threat to the discovery crew
only insofar as how commanded all
aspects of the discovery so it would
have to be with a super intelligence
would have to have dominion over all of
our world this is the stuff of Skynet
from the movie The Terminator in which
we had a super intelligence that
commanded human will that directed every
device that was in every corner of the
world practically speaking it ain't
going to happen we are not building a is
that control the weather the
direct the tides that command us
capricious chaotic humans and
furthermore if such an artificial
intelligence existed you would have to
compete with human economies and thereby
compete for resources with us and in the
end don't tell fury this we can always
unplug them we are on an incredible
journey of coevolution with our machines
the humans we are today are not the
humans we will be then to worry now
about the rise of a super intelligence
is in many ways a dangerous distraction
because the rise of computing itself
brings to us a number of human and
societal issues to which we must now
attend
how shall I best organize society when
the need for human labor diminishes how
can I bring understanding and education
throughout the globe and still respect
our differences how might I extend and
enhance human life through cognitive
health care how might I use computing to
help take us to the Stars and that's the
exciting thing the opportunities to use
computing to advance the human
experience are within our reach here and
now too we are just beginning thank you
very much
[Applause]